the Cera outbreak in bohara District in
southeast Zimbabwe's Mana land province
is one of the worst in 15 years back in
2008 4,000 people died from the
disease One Survivor of the latest
outbreak Steven Mingo suspects he was
infected at work hospitalized for almost
a week he says he sought treatment early
and is lucky to be
alive I spent three days at home with
diarrhea then I started vomiting I tried
to eat but I kept vomiting I started
sweating and drank a lot of water but I
contined to feel
weak authorities are blaming poor
sanitation and water shortages with few
B holes in the area this is the only
source of water for many households it's
used for everything from cleaning to
drinking the government has limited the
number of people attending funerals and
other public Gatherings to no more than
50 it suspects that more than 4,600
people may be infected witha we have now
taken the issue to train our village
health workers our environmental health
technicians in the community the
community leaders to be able to identify
those members in the community who could
have contacted the
disease while some businesses have been
closed to stop the spread there's
concern not enough is being done to deal
with the
outbreak the problem is not new we've
had it for a while now but there used to
be health workers who'd move around
communities Distributing water
purification tablets that we could use
to treat open Wells that isn't happening
anymore so far 41 districts in Zimbabwe
have reported cases famida m al
jaaz make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from
aljer